hey good evening and welcome to
washington i'm john roberts in for bret
baer tonight breaking tonight president
biden says
he is willing to negotiate on how to pay
for his massive job creation plan
but he insists it has to be paid for
this evening
we will look at how much money the
president wants to spend where he's
going to get that money and how many
jobs are expected to be created the
numbers don't quite add up
white house correspondent peter ducey
starts us off tonight hi peter
good evening john the by ni the biden
administration
is starting to use summer holidays as
goal posts
covet safe safe gatherings they want by
the 4th of july
progress on an infrastructure package
they want by memorial day
this is a blue collar blueprint and
there's some
wiggle room when it comes to how high
he'll raise corporate taxes
i'm willing to negotiate that the
president wants to raise corporate taxes
from 21 percent to 28.
democrat joe manchin favors a smaller
hike to 25 percent
which makes him a powerful man i think
he's in a position
in a 50-50 senate to get whatever he
wants and one key
biden ally in congress is guessing the
current 2.25
trillion dollar white house proposal may
be too big
to pass i do think that there is an
opportunity here
for us to come together around a smaller
package and by smaller i mean
hundreds of billions of dollars that is
directly targeted at hard infrastructure
president biden
is still thinking big it's the single
largest investment in american jobs
since world war
ii how many jobs is that moody suggests
it would create
19 billion jobs but a close review of
that moody's report finds a forecast
that
even without this multi-trillion dollar
plan the us economy
is projected to create 16 million jobs
over the next decade
anyway and with the plan fewer than 3
million additional jobs which fox
business calculates out to about
830 000 per job
they see the american economy creating
19 million jobs
and that's 2.7 more than if this bill
doesn't pass the big pr push for white
house officials is
redefining infrastructure as being about
more than roads and bridges to include
replacing lead pipes there's hundreds of
flints
all across america and encouraging green
innovation
imagine a world where you and your
family can travel coast to coast without
a single tank of gas
or in a high-speed train close to as
fast as you can
go across the country in a plane all
funded by new taxes
on businesses i'm trying to punish
anybody
but damn it maybe it's because i come
from a middle class neighborhood
i'm sick and tired of ordinary people
being fleeced
and tonight i've confirmed to the white
house official that tomorrow
president biden is going to take a
combination of steps
to improve background checks for guns
i've also
confirmed he plans to nominate as atf
director
that gentleman on the screen david
chipman a former atf
agent and a current gun control advocate
john we'll look forward to your
reporting on all of that tomorrow peter
ducey for us from the white house
tonight peter thank you